catskil like you have to learn how to be
a cat like no I really remember Jennifer
saying she had to like you know learn
how to like actually like embody a cat
yeah definitely so everybody had to go
to cat school me I stayed so cat school
basically is there's a there's a woman
who is it Barry okay she's not like a
cat psychologist she's so basically she
gives you all this not everything I say
sounds ridiculous in my mind it's not
ridiculous it's gonna be awesome
it's gonna be amazing yeah so the the
actual cat school so basically she just
tells you everything to bet you have
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
some cats walk in in a different way
right they walk same arm same leg so
it's a little different than us so I
mean it's all those little all those
yeah I just pictured myself yeah so it's
it's like that because we go from two
feet to four feet because we're not
we're not like just regular cats we're
like cat people so if we go in you know
from from standing in a you know two
feet and took going into all fours so
you so you'll be in a in a conversation
with somebody Hayek's yeah yes a lot of
core so you'll be on two feet and then
users be having a conversation that's
why they call me
Oh
[Applause]
I'm gonna show my man that clip I may be
like what you do that tonight I want you
to come at me and be like I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this